[拍手]
[音楽]
こんにちは
今日私は被災地の復興は日本の復興だというような話をさせていただこうと思います
それに当たって僕がどんな活動をこれまでしてきたのかそしてなぜそういう考えに至っ
たのかって話をしたいと思うんですが
今写っている写真震災前の私です
私は震災前は普通の会社員でした
この表情を見てください
ea 顔してるでしょ
女性に囲まれているから笑顔なわけではなくて
仕事がすごく楽しくてですね最高の仲間に恵まれて非常に行こう楽しく仕事を毎日して
ました
ただある日を境に僕の人生が大きく変わりました
それは2011年の3月11日です
この日は東日本大震災が発生した日です
私はこのとき札幌にいました
札幌でただただ自分の呼吸である宮城県の町が津波で治る津波で襲われる姿を一晩中
ずっとテレビで見てました
そしてですね
何か役立ちたいと思って札幌か週末は仙台に帰ってきて
そして a
あのもともと会社でお世話になっていたクライアントさんを中心にボランティアであっ
たりとか
顔出しに行ったりとかそういうことを毎週繰り返してました
そんな中であることを考えたんですね
自分自社何のために生きるんだろうって考えたんです
僕こんなこと考えたことなかったんです会社員の頃
前月仕事も楽しくて毎日1日1日を楽しく過ごせればいいかなというふうに思ってたん
ですけど
震災で被災地に行ってという土日はボランティアをして平日働いてその繰り返しの中で
自分は何のために生きようって大きなとにぶつかったんです
それで僕は本当に悩んで悩んで
あのひとつ決めたことがあります
今まで自分は
素直に生きてきたかなと
もしかして素直に来てないかもしれない今私はもう心も完全に被災地に行っていると
だから
思いに素直に生きて被災地で自分にできることをやってみようかなと思ったんです
それで2011年の9月末に解釈会社を辞めて
それでいろんな街被災地ですね宮城県の被災地を回りました
行政民間企業団体いろんな団体さんそれから個人の方いろんな方に話を聞きながら
自分は被災地のために行きたいと思っているけど何ができるかということを考えてまし
た
そうやっていろんな街をこう何回も何十回も回っている中で出会ったのが
女川町という待ちでした
女川町はこちらです
女川町は東日本大震災の日もちろん被災地ではあるんですけども非常に大きな被害を
受けました
街の80%が流出してしまいいい
そして約1割の方の命がなくなりました
この街に私が飛び込んだ時に
町の方に言われたのは
何度もいいから来週末手伝ってくれと
こいと言われたんですね
いろんな町を回ってきた初めてでした声をかけていただいたのは
だから私はこの街で
仕事をしようで自分にできることは走りながら考えようと思ってまずは女川だという
ことで尾長で活動することを決意しました
それ決意をした時に色々とこの会社を辞めてから自分のキャリアをつくっていく中で
アドバイスをしてくれた先輩たちにお礼のメールを送ったんです
女川で活動することを決意しましたと
そしたらこんなメールが来たんですね
被災地の復興は日本の復興だと
だからお前頑張れというメールが来たんです
最初僕はよくわかりませんでした
僕は被災地の自分の呼吸で宮城県の被災地の役に立ちたいと思って
会社を辞めてお腹に入っ
日本って大きすぎるなと思ったんですね
どういうことだろうと考えたんです
それで少しずつ答えがわかってきたんです
これ
日本の人口の長期トレンドです
日本はこれから人口が減っていくという
グラフになってますけども今いろんなことところで人口減少の話が出ます
被災地どうですかと
震災が来る前から人口減ってたんです少子化高齢化経済の縮小
そういう課題も持ってたんです
ソコギいい
津波が来てしまって
多くの方が亡くなってさらに人口流出が起こり
ある意味日本で一番そういった社会課題を抱えている場所になったんです
つまり被災地というのは日本の課題先進地だと
だからこそ
先輩はきっとをここで女川でお前がやる活動というのは
日本の色々なこれから抱える社会課題を先に取り組んでいく
そして街をつくる復興していく
そういう場所だから
二日本の
復興という目線を持ってやれって言ったんだと思いました
僕はそれでもまだ二にの中こうなんていうかねはらい落ちないというかですね
確かにそうだなと思いながら他の場所はどうなんだろうと思ったんです
僕は縁があっていろんな海外の経済危機であったりとか災害危機が起こった町に行き
ました
そこに行くとやはり同じようなことが起きているんですね
大きな危機が起こったあとに新しい社会の形であったりとか
もしくは価値観というものが生まれてそれが口に広がっていくということが起きている
んです
それはなぜかというと
大きな地球の中に
社会というものがあって
その中でその中の地域でいろいろな危機が起こります
そこに対して危機が起きるとそこに住む人
そしてそこを支援しようと集まってくる人たちがその社会に対してどのように自分たち
は関わる方真剣に考えるんですね
そしてその輪がどんどんどんどん広がって
日本あの新しい社会の形と価値観が生まれて
そして復興が元に戻すではなくて新しい社会の形につながって復興行われていくって
いうことが起きていたんです
僕はなるほどと思ったんですね日本のかうん今の被災地は日本の課題先進地であり
そしてそこで起こっていることっていうのは自分自身がその社会に対してどう関わるか
ということを考えるということなんだと
尾長でも同じようなことを受けたんですもう一度目を向けると
街で働くこと
そして暮らすことこれはどの街に住んでいても皆さんが考えること
皆さんがすることです
それにやっぱりプラスアルファでまちの未来に関わるということを考えているんですね
街の方に来ました
いやでもまちの未来に関わる皆さんすごいですねいやでも震災があって色々と苦労した
いろいろ振動思いましたしつらい思いもたくさんしたと
でもこうやって
生き残った以上おまちの未来に関わるんだと
神様購入動きはなかったと
未来をつくるんだとそういう町の皆さんいました
僕は改めてその話をした時にあここで生まれていく
いろいろな復興の形というのは本当に日本の復興につながるものが生まれていくんだな
というふうに強く感じました
もうそこにはですね
行政とか民間という勝つかではないんですね
女川の中でもみんなそれぞれがまちの未来に関わろうとしていて
自分は行政マンだから自分は企業だからとかそういうことを一度通り越して
1個人として自分はどのどうやってその地域に関わるかまちの未来に関わるのかという
ことを考えるんですね
でその中で自分が属している組織がたまたま行政
もしくは民間 npo そういうものがあってそれぞれの役割というものじゃどういう
役割であったらこの社会課題解決できるかなということを生み出してるっていうのが
復興なんです
collective インパクトという言葉がありますけどまさにコレクティブ
インパクトが起こっているということが復興だというふうに思います
ちょっと
抽象度の高い話をしたので具体的な話をしていきたいとおもいます
今女川で復興過程の中で尾長の町民の健康のプロジェクトをやっているんです
今日本の中では医療費の問題というのは大きな問題になってますよね
これをながも一緒なんです
せっ震災前から生活習慣があったしていてそこに震災があって生活環境が変化して
そして a
にあのそこに住む人たちの体調が悪くなりました
さらに健康診断を受けた後の指導というものを受けない方が多くて
結果病気の治療が遅れて医療費が増えるということを着てたんです
日本で起こっていることが地方でも来てる先ほどお話ししたみたいに日本のある意味
先進地だと思っています
こういうことが起きているか体の中で何をしなきゃいけないか
大事なことは医療費を下げるということは
病気になる前の改善つまり4房入りをするということが大事なんですね
ただ予防医療をどうやったらいいかわからないです
行政の方とも話をした時にどうしようどうやったら予防色できるんだろう
いやそれぞれみんながここに今いろんな人たちが集まって地域の中の人だけではなく外
の人も集まっているとそれぞれの役割分担の中でこの予防医療に本気で取り組み
ましょうと話をしました
そして予防医療の専門性を持っている企業と
それから住民の情報をよく知っている
行政
そしてそういった公と民をつなぐ npo
その3社がパートナーになって一緒にそれぞれの役割のもとこの復興過程の中で予防
医療のいろんな取り組みをやっていこうと
よボールの専門も専門性を持っている企業さんはここで行っている取り組みが成功すれ
ば日本に広がるとそれは商品なのかサービスなのかまだわからないけれどもここから
ココでやることが結果日本の予防医療につながると信じているという風に言ってくれ
ました
こういうことなんですね
そこのパートナーの中にさらにいろんな企業さんであったりとか大学さんであった
npo さんが参画できるように開いています
さらにアメリカで
すでに予防医療を取り組んでいる npo とも連携をしてそして今
町民の方々の
健康を作ろうというような授業をやっています
これ行政の方がいいました
震災がなければこんなこと絶対起きなかったと
震災というものは先ほど話をしたみたいに元に戻すことじゃないんですね
新しく新しいものを生み出すことなんですまさにこういう新しい動きがこうやって
女川の中で生まれてそしてそこから日本拡がろうというふうにしています
最後に私が地域で活動するときに
大事にしている言葉をご紹介して終わりにしたいと思います
この方は二宮尊徳という形です
二宮金次郎と言ったほうがわかりやすいかもしれません
彼は江戸時代に
荒廃した村尾
農業を通して再生させてきた人です
彼はいろんな村に行って荒廃した土地を地元の人たちと一緒に
もう一度農地としてタダやしてそして
2あの再生させて街として成り立たせるということをやってたんですね
彼が彼のところにいろんな方が訪ねてくるんです
彼は何を言ったかその方々にこんなこと言ったんです
一村救済できる工法は一国を救済できると
その原理は同じなんだという話をしたんですね
まさに今女川でやっていることそれがもしかして国を救えるかもしれない
僕はこの言葉すごく大事にしています
合わせて
ある村で
その再生を取り組んでいる時に身の実は損得が言った言葉があります
目の前の仕事に全力を尽くせと
それが何全国の役に立つと
僕は改めてこの言葉を見て選んで
尾長まで全力を尽くしてそしてそこから全国を救う役に立つようなことをいろいろと
生み出していければなというふうに思っています
女川の復興は日本の復興
僕自身はそのように信じて今活動してます
僕にはたくさんの仲間がいます
この写真は女川町のある飲み屋さんに撮った写真ですけれどもこの中には町長もいれば
行政の方もいれば
地元の民間企業の方もいれば
グローバルの展開する企業の方もいます
そういういろんな人たちがいろんな意見をぶつけ合ってそしてそれぞれの役割の下で
新しい
そう新しいことを発送して想像して復興なし得ていく
それが今東北
いろんなところで起こっています尾長でも凝ってます
僕はこういった仲間の仲間たちと一緒に
女川復興を通して日本の復興に役立ちたいなというふうに思っております
私の思いはもう全て込めてここで話した
形になりますので
ぜひ女川れ
成功させて日本に広げていきたいというふうに思っております
ありがとうございました
[拍手]